Luke Bryan punches a heckler for making  crude gestures during a live performance  the 40-year old country singer took a  swing at a man while he was performing  his latest hit loop while on stage in  Nashville Tennessee on Wednesday  Luke was at the volunteer jam benefiting  military families all the drama unfolded  after Luke saw the heckler in the crowd  make gestures toward him that included  his middle finger  the man was immediately escorted out by  the Bridgestone Arena security Luke has  yet to comment on the incident himself  but his rep tells et in a statement  quote it was insulting not only to him  but more importantly to the men women  and families sitting around him who were  there to support and celebrate the  efforts of raising money for the  military veterans  you